Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Acting Flav.
This is acting lab model stream
number 3.1.
It's May 27th, 2021.
And we're here with Tim
for Ballin and Ozone Kettle today.
We're going to have a model stream
on some of their recent work on learning
generative state space models
for active inference.
We're going to have a presentation
followed by some time for question
and answer.
So please feel free
to write any questions
in the chat and we will get to them
in the conversation.
So thanks again to Tim
and Ozen for joining us today.
We're really looking forward
to what you have to share,
so please take it away and thanks again.
For or so.
Thank you, Daniel, for having us.
So I'm Tim Burton and together
with the table, we will talk a bit
on our paper on learning
state space models for active inference.
So we are both researchers
that I make university in Belgium.
If you want to know more
about what we do,
you can read about it on our blog
or follow us on Twitter
on the rest over at the Smart Robots.
So before we dove
in, maybe a short introduction
on what we do, what our goal is.
So basically we want to build
intelligent robots in our lab.
Understand
we have a pretty big research base
where we have some room
for robot manipulators on the one hand,
but also driving and flying robots
on the other hand.
We typically all kinds of sensors
on these things,
and then we want to process
a source of information and infer
some useful actions, for instance,
and of course effective inference.
This agreement,
the biology to try also to
further
investigate and it's in this context
that basically this this work,
this is being done
so why would you bother learning
state space?
So if you look at
active inference, the papers
from the recent years then typically
you will find a figure
like the ones that are on the slide.
So you have this figure of
what is the kind of environments
that you're building
that you were investigating
and then a whole description
of how the model should look like.
So you define a safe space.
And then
possibly in the case of the streets,
state space, as you defined
the so-called A, B, C and D matrix,
that's
the size of the model.
So what is the likelihood
to see a certain observation
when you're in a certain state
or other transition models?
How do you transition from one state
to another and so forth?
And recently, while we were doing this
research research,
we saw some other people
also thinking about, you
can be do more learning
using these these kind of multiple
deploying techniques in these
in respect of inference methods.
So, yes, for example, take also for
who said
those two basically
learn kind of a state space
for for the multicore.
But then still
he needed to explicitly encode
some of the of the information in state
after
there was also some work from from
from there
in Munich who basically
that's learning.
But more on learning the policy
rather than the state space.
So this could use more of
this is your process
with small state spaces where you would
basically just deal with the
the raw state space the reservations
that I gave you where
we're basically suited as a state space.
I think would
then if you would then investigate
how to learn the actions
given given these states.
Our work is basically on
what if you don't know the state space,
what if your observations are dimensional
and you cannot really use these directly
as your state space?
How do you define the model?
How are you going to
and maybe as a concrete example, suppose
you have
one of our driving robots in the lab.
So this this is the first person
view of the robots.
This is the kind of observation that
you get is just the square of pixels.
And then what's
what is your state's business space?
It might be an x y position on the map.
That might be something relevant
for robots as a state.
It might also be what child?
You're approaching a gable gooder.
So there might be a
that might also be something useful.
Maybe the items that are
stored in direct order
or relevant for whatever task.
So that might also be
part of state space.
Maybe there are human workers
that that walk around
that you also need to model these.
So depending on your robots
and the use case, you have those
get tense and what's going to happen
in the environments, it's becomes
to to define kind of a
precise set of states
that you want to break,
let alone that you need some model
that's that
that models this like how do you get
from pixels to your X by position
so there are certain methods
in robotics
that's to do part of these things,
but none of them really just figure out
what is the complete state
space that you need
for whatever you want to do,
and especially not
in kind of an active inference
so before we go into
our methods, I'll briefly
talk about active inference.
Probably most of you
are already familiar with the topic,
but I'll just rehearse
some of that stuff.
Even if it's just to to get accustomed
through our way of, of,
of notation, let's say,
because everybody has its own
notation and it means
it will put us all on the same page
for the next part.
So it all starts with having an agent
that needs to interact
with the environment and the agents.
It's assumed to be kind of separate
from the environments,
from the so-called blankets.
So on the one hand,
the agents can come from actions.
These actions, the,
these will impact young humans,
which is kind of a change of process
that has some, some, some hidden states
and that provides
you, given your action, it provides
you with some sensory observation.
So in this case, an action
could be for the robots to drive around
with some runs on the motors,
and observation could be some pixels
from from the camera.
And then the goal of the agents
is to build
this model where he has his own
events, his own state space,
basically the device.
How actions
have effects on on the states
and how these states then
then generate these these certifications.
So the question is how can you build this
model
that actually comes up automatically?
It's kind of a proper state space
to learn this model
so basically
the drive this model that looks like
a partially observable
Markov decision process.
So it just means that we assume that
that's a state
that's a given time, that it only depends
on the previous states and the action
that's that's you were doing.
And each states
gives or gives rise to certain sufficient
and so then we end up
with the so-called free energy principle.
That's basically what we want to do
is run to build the model
that's that maximizes look evidence.
So here you see the formula for energy
and you can come back in several ways
so the first rate is basically
by base stating
that minimizing free energy is actually
maximizing the, the, the everything.
So balance, let's say.
And if you're at this free energy
minimum,
then basically you have your approximate
steward that is actually equals
to your
or very close to your your triple steer.
But then the the third line is basically
what we typically use for
optimizing our model, which is basically
on the one hand complexity.
Third, you want to
have your
your state's explain explained away
as simple as possible, whereas
you want to have the highest accuracy
to predict whatever you're observing
so in this case, for variation
or for example, steer
is something that maps observations
and actions
into inferring your preference state
but what about the future?
So in the past you basically knew
which actions you were doing
and you saw the observations
that came in.
So you kind of
infer which states would have given rise
to that observations.
So that's basically
the creation of the false.
But then in the future
things change a bit
because now
you don't know what you will observe.
And also you have to select actions.
You will do so
in your actions you will basically
denote them as being generated
by so-called policy.
But in this case,
the policy is basically just
what is a certain sequence
of actions basically.
And you
now have to create some expectations
not only on future states
but also on future observations.
So what's which state?
I think I will visit
by doing some actions, but also
what kind of observations do
I think that I will see
if I visit these states.
So then the energy becomes
the so-called expected free energy
and again, you can then take this thing,
this thing
as follows.
So basically what happens is again,
you have on the one hand, your
probability of your steer model.
Mine is low probability of your
OK for this model.
And now the difference
is that that you don't know
yet the observations in the future
so yet you condition that on the policy.
So everything will depend on the actions
you will do.
And you also have to take the expectation
over all kinds of of outcomes you expect.
And then
going to the second line, you basically
make the move that after
if you
if your model is sufficiently trained,
then basically your
your true
your approximate posterior
will be very close to the true steer.
And this then basically allows you to,
to rewrite the final term
scene that I
that I wrote it in a different way.
But you can you can rewrite this address
and information gain on your
your state's and
moving towards different outcomes.
You can also rewrite the view that here
where you basically
state, OK, at some point in the future
I will visit some states.
So this is this is the given the policy
and you basically replace this
by by some prior belief that's regardless
which policy I'm actually choosing.
I believe that's some point in the future
I will realize my preferences.
So that's why you lose the
the conditioning on the policy
in the last iteration.
So this then basically becomes the key
other versions of this.
OK, I, I want to find the policies
that actually bring me close
to states that I,
that I prefer that I like to be into.
And then on the other hand, you have this
ambiguity term that says, OK,
what I don't like is to visit states
that can give me like any observation
that I cannot predict.
So I don't like these ambiguous states
where I don't really understand
basically what's happening
so that brings us to the
the whole active instance scheme.
So at each time step,
you basically evaluate
your expected free energy
for each of your policies
and you then basically assume
that you will choose the policy
that will actually minimize your energy.
So you, you take the max over
minus G and you also rate this with this
gamma parameter just like the precision.
So if you have a high precision,
then basically you will
you will have a very big output
of the suffix function.
So with the suffix,
it will basically become
a mix.
So you then definitely choose the policy
with lowest expected tree energy
if you relax the, the,
the precision, the bits, then
basically you allow for some
or some more randomness in the system.
And then basically you end up
inferring the next section according to
what is the, the, the next action that
I should take according to this policy.
So in the words follows the actual
the action
selection, given the policy is basically
just deterministic method.
So so the policies are just like
certain sequence of actions.
So given once you choose the policy,
the actions are basically fixed.
But in theory you could also make this
a probabilistic mapping.
So let's now go to the really interesting
parts of the work.
This is how do we learn state spaces
with deep neural networks
in such an interesting
so basically
we have two components.
One is the chair.
This model
that I rehearse from the first slide
and we have our approximate
posterior model and basically you can see
that there are three parts
in these situations.
And the first part
is basically the transition model.
So its outputs,
the probability of birth states,
given your previous states
and the action you did
in the second part.
And also the the initial state
is basically also part of this model.
But then you just provide us
with the zero action,
for example, just to bootstrap it
the second part is in the electric model.
So given state, you want to have a model
that that predicts
what kind of observation you will
you will see
and then finally
you have the posterior model
that's given the previous states action.
And your current observation
also is to predict
which state you're also assuming
for which state you were in.
So basically the procedure model
is to come up with the same thing
as transition model.
But in addition,
it has access to your observation this
and again similar to
Transition Mobile to bootstrap this
for the initial summation,
you don't have any action,
but it can be modeled by
by the same thing
as to all this, these three components,
we basically instance gives us deep
neural nets where
they have to
basically be trained
to come up with these three models
so if we this in a schematic,
we basically have something like this.
So given your state an action
from the previous time step
and your observation
from the current time step, you on
the one hand provides the previous state
and action to your transition model,
which will then outputs
the distribution over different states.
And in this case,
the distribution is basically modeled
as move to various custom distribution.
So basically
the output of the neural nets
will be the means
and the third deviations of regression.
And so you basically use
this distribution to then
generate samples for the next step.
And so the posterior model gets also US
inputs the state
and the action from previous step.
But also in addition
the current observation,
it also does a prediction on the
the current time step and after sampling
basically of the
model that can then generates
the prediction of the outcome.
And then this states
this puts to the next time step
and the story repeats
so as I already mentioned,
the output of each of our neural nets
is basically so
and so variation of
the aggression with
and with the diagonal covariance matrix
and we use the V from position trick
to generate samples.
So basically we generate the sample
by having the the means
and then at the standard deviation time,
some standard normal noise.
And this basically allows you
to vector propagate
regions all the way true.
And this new and that's also if you
if you draw samples from
from the models
and then of course
for the next step you just propagate
the sample and then the this
so creating such a model is done
basically
first collecting the data sets of action
observation sequences.
So you take your, your,
your agents, you either let it randomly
generate sequences in the environments
or in case in real trouble.
For example, you drive it around yourself
in the environment
while you record the actions
and the observations
and while the models have converged,
you sample
some sequences from your data sets, you
your dates, the states that are visited,
and you reconstruct all the observations,
and then you basically propagates
the free energy loss.
So this is the the same formula
as the free energy starts.
On the one hand,
you have the yield divergence
between the output of your sphere,
your inlets and your prior units,
and on the other on the other hand,
you have this reconstruction error
that basically scores
how how good your reconstructing
the actual traffic
and using this lost function.
You just dates the parameters
of your units
and you basically build
a model that is able, on the one hand, to
infer your
current state, given your observation
that is able to generate new observations
if you know which state you're in,
you can reconstruct these observations.
But also you have a transition model
that you can then just use to
in the state space plan ahead
what would happen if I
if I were through this action
and it's really give you a distribution
over over the next state, basically
so that we come to the planning part.
So once you have this model,
how can you use it to let your agent do
useful, useful, useful things
so there we we will use Google sampling.
So one of the things, one of
the limitations of these kind of pictures
is that basically only approximates
the distribution for the next states.
So given the samples
from from the previous states
and given the action
the approximate distribution
for the next stage of them, samples
you're creating as well.
So we will never have like a
grid distribution
for let's say ten steps ahead
so victim distributions
for for further in the future,
we approximate these values
by doing multiple
so for each of the policies we want to be
and we want to
evaluate which sample and trajectories
that's that all do the same actions.
But the to the sampling
might give us different results
in terms of future states and motivations
for each type stuff.
We don't have a bunch of states
and a bunch of predictable observations.
We don't fit regression distribution
using the sample means and variances
and then we estimate
the expected energy as follows.
So on the one hand,
we have this yellow divergence.
If you remember that scores of goods,
your distribution of states
is according to some some prior,
some prior preferences of states.
So you use this this is normal,
this discussion distribution
to go through the divergence
with respect to disperse.
And on the other hand,
you have this entropy term
that scores
the ambiguity of these states.
So you you basically use
then the entropy of the
the observations
generated in our trajectories.
And we also added the scale factor rule.
You just kind of wait two thirds
from one another,
which allows you to make an agents
more risky, let's say,
if it's it's more
based on realizing references early red.
Or you could also make a more cautious
agent let's say that's
that's really does not want to end up
in some some ambiguous states
and crucially here
we also have kind of this
recursive notion in here. So
we do this roll out for ten steps ahead
and then for the future you could kind of
recursively
look further into the future
let's say aggregates
also expected energies
from from that point
and make it more clear and
let's try to visualize this a bit better.
So suppose at some given times
that you're in the states
then basically what you do
is you use your transition model to say,
OK, given that I fall or we'll see one
what would be the next states and
you draw a sample from the distribution.
So this is then test this one by forming
both C one
and this thing you can repeat four times.
So we re within this,
this K to just have some kind of
box grading of actions.
Say for example, in the case of A
for driving robots,
it might not make sense to switch action
every
ten milliseconds, let's say.
So if you see
if you decide to drive forward,
you want to keep on driving forward
towards this time.
So that's basically what we're just
this comes from.
So you follow the same policy
first four steps
and you basically sampled this end times
so you you repeats this
this process and times.
So you have now at each time
step and samples for the kind of states
you think you will visit
after following the first policy.
And then if you have a second policy
you can do the same thing for
this policy.
So in this case,
we only consider
potential policies, for instance,
go left or right, let's say.
And then
at this point, so it states that
we can basically repeats
this procedure and say, OK, what if
what if off
time stops a switch policy, maybe,
maybe a first left to go left
and and before turning right
or maybe third place.
So then basically you repeat this process
and this you can basically
keep from adding to the search tree
for as long as your computation power
allows you.
Let's see
so then how do we calculate
the expected free energy from this?
So we take our formula.
So basically what we do is that each time
step, we first use likelihood model
to also predict what are the observations
that are expected in states
and you then
look at all your state samples
from a certain time step.
And this then gives you this this
approximate version distribution
for both the states and the observations.
So you plug this into the formula
and this then gives you kind of a number
that says this is the expected
free energy, if I think I will,
omitting states
plus K and I will follow along
with policy one from thereafter.
And then basically you can do this
for each,
each of these branches and this is
then gravity recursion comes in.
So then we basically states, well,
I assume that's
my active inference agents
also at that times step will
most likely choose the policy bits
the the, the, the lowest tree energy.
So basically you combine
the, the free energy for pulse.
You want obviously
to according to the weights
that are provided using this
suffix function so if one of the
if policy one has a very,
very low expected three energy
compared to two, then basically only
the expected to be energy of, of policy.
One will be accidents thereafter.
If they are kind of the same
then they will both have kind of
0.5 rate or if the other one is the key
will mainly be the contribution of this.
The so we basically combine these
assuming that's
your agent at this point also selects the
the the possible to this region.
So now we basically have an estimate of
what will be the expected free energy
for the future given
that we are at the step interest rate.
And then we can further go upstream.
And so then for, for each branch again
we will use the first part
of the formula to
estimate these these versions
calculate together versions and beta
and then add this together.
It's what we already had
for the or the, the,
the remaining part of three basically.
And this is,
this is very similar I think to what's
called system proportions
sophisticated inference paper.
So basically it's at each step
in the future, you,
you kind of only consider the free energy
of the branches that you think
this could be the best months.
So in the end,
you end up with the expected free energy
for both of your policies
and you then select
the best one and start acting accordingly
so I'll now turn
to also will give some more details
on all the various
experiments that we did that
hopefully give some more insights
on how this can work in practice
so they can reuse them.
Yeah, I
I have some echoing in
my and maybe it's results now.
Yeah, sounds fine.
Thank you.
OK, and so I'll go briefly
through our initial experiences
experiments so that these are
the experiments we did in
the past one or two years.
And so one of the first experiments
we did and reported on
was the mountain car, which is a
very well known benchmark, I think.
So the goal is to have
this indirect rated car so it has not
does not have enough power
to reach the top of
the right hand mountain
but you want to reach it anyway.
So ideally, your agent should learn here
that it should
first go back to the left
to gain momentum,
to gain enough momentum so it can climb
the steeper mount on the right.
And even though this is such a low
dimensional problem,
it only has positions and velocities,
it is actually a very interesting
benchmark to experiment upon
because there's no easy solution.
So any agent that
just wants to realize its preferences
immediately will fail at this
because it will always fail
to drive up the mountain
and now for our experiments,
we made it a bit more difficult.
We made the fully observable
amount of car, partially observable
so what we did was
we submitted the velocity information
and only provided some noisy
estimates of the actual position.
So the agents actually
had to learn two things.
It had to learn, first of all,
what its precise position was,
and then also how this position relates
to the momentum by its velocity.
And then
if we take if we start from the setup
and we train the model
that explained a bit earlier
and in its most basic form,
you can actually learn a state space
that closely mimics
these physical constraints of the system
by minimizing energy.
So if you look at the right most figure,
you'll see that
and you see these sinusoidal
state space dimensions
and this goes closely mimic the actual
observations of the real world
in the lower image.
So as you can see in the lower image,
we have the ground truth in green,
which is an actual trajectory
through its position of the cars
and then also our state
transitional estimate.
So our prior estimates on the position
without observing
and then also in the blue line,
which is a bit harder to see,
you can see the same estimate,
but now correct it with the observations.
So it's actually just
the posterior model outwards.
And you
can see these
shapes returning in the state space,
which in itself does not say that much,
but it gives you
at least a kind of vague idea
that at least
the state space is sketching
something relevant for the problem.
And I think there's one
more animation on this.
Guess so?
Yeah, it's the same conclusion.
As I said, right now
you can predict the future,
as you can see in the Orange Line
and it appears to learn the velocity
in its state space.
Now, if you can go to the next slides
yeah.
And now
we want to actually figure out how
how we can use this model that we learned
for active inference.
And typically in RL
you would get some sparse reward
for driving up the mountain.
But in our initial experiments,
we were more interested in
how an agent could learn from human
observations or demonstrations.
So we recorded
seven, I think five or five
human roll out in the environment,
just like driving around with the car.
So you go first left and right
and then we
push these trajectories
through our models together
to our through our posterior model
to get a preferred state solution.
So here on this figure,
you can see the eight different
dimensions, how these evolve through time
if you follow these trajectories.
So in this thread, of course, give
you gives you the standard deviation
at each time point
four for the X state value.
And then
if you use this
these is preferred state distribution
and you calculate the degree or this
or even only to a divergence
between your posterior and your
preferred distribution
for different trajectories through time.
So here every different color,
every different trajectory is a different
roll out in the environment.
Or imaginary
relative to the environments.
You can see that
you can actually use this
this preferred distribution
to rank trajectories according to
lowest free energy.
So you see that the blue curve
is the only one that reaches the top
and is also
the one that the model seems to prefer
and then in the next slide, yes,
we experiment about what this means
in terms of the actual free energy.
So also compensate it with the entropy
and what we did here was we
if that we had the agent
observe the world for one time step.
So we give it an initial observation to
get a sense of bootstrap latent sample.
And then we will only use the prior model
to imagine
what will happen
if you follow certain policies.
So here we considered three policies
or like two possible policies
that you can switch at three time steps.
So e to go left, right, right, left,
right, left, et cetera.
Or you can start with right.
And then these are the blue curves
you see that if there is no
initial velocity, then
you see that
agent imagines that the optimal policy,
which is left, right, right.
So first go as far left
and then just blast your way to the top
and give us actually
the least amount the spread.
And also he believes that this will reach
the top earlier than any other policy.
Inversely, if you look at the
the policy that the first goal rates
and then you see that
there is still a little
and close to noise breath
due to the lack of initial velocity.
But it's already knows that
it's impossible to reach the top.
Now if you go to the next slides,
the slides.
So here we do the the same experiments,
but we add some random initial velocity.
And again, we let the agent
observe the world for one time set
and then plan
according to the same policies as before.
First of all, you
see that the agents
has lots of a much larger spread.
Then it's believed outcomes.
This is due to this external extra
uncertainty on
what the initial velocity is.
And also this initial velocity
might render
previously infeasible policies
feasible as you can see at the bottom.
Because now if the agent thinks, yes,
my initial velocity is high enough,
even with the one of the more
suboptimal policies
might still be possible
for me to reach the top
and and if you go to the next slide,
please,
here, we can then see this in action.
So this animation we collapse
the imagined trajectories
to the actual trajectory.
And you see that
in the beginning,
if we can play it again,
in the beginning it believes that more
red policies will reach the top.
And as it gains more momentum,
all it will believe
that all blue policies will reach the top
and even it will know that
if I now go left
so I decelerates,
then I will less likely reach the top.
So so I think here.
So as you can see now,
he knows that you will not reach the top
and yes,
and then another experiment
we did, building upon this was
what if we take this same approach?
But now we move to the task,
the kind of problems
we want to solve this
so the high dimensional
observations
that you cannot model by hands.
So we took another open
engine environment the the car racer.
And here the goal is to drive
the red car, as you can see
in the high resolution image on the left
and on the road for as long as you can.
And then we trained our model
on a handful
of human demonstrations of this
and then you can see that
in the reconstructed image on the right,
it's already it's
even on a handful of observations
that can learn to predict this
so we
did exactly the same thing as before.
And I think this is an emotional.
Yeah.
So if you then use the exact
the planning theory
that explained on this little cart,
it will have learned to that
the the road.
So the gray area is important
and it should stay on this.
Now, this agent is a bit more greedy
since it tries to shortcut corners
to get quicker on the gray path.
As you can see here,
OK, if we can go to the next slide,
maybe so now.
And also an important point here
is that our active inference
approach, which is model based,
seems to be a lot
more data efficient.
That seems to be a lot more data
efficient than, for example, at
a baseline age.
And so we took decline
since this is also an of policy algorithm
to be able to compare, it's
kind of similar to our approach
and as you can see in the first graph,
so for the mountain car and
our model quickly and
so our models are in is the orange
our more quickly learns that
at least some method to reach the top
and then afterwards
it just improves upon this else
due to this part of the reports
Ukraine is not able to learn as quickly
and even after having
thousand times more thousand times
more observations, it still isn't capable
of planning the month
and even for the car race, it's
even worse.
So here
we trained on seven or ten rollouts
and immediately we're able
to get a reward of six hundreds
while Deakin
just fails
to get the same level of performance,
even after thousands of rollouts
in the environments.
So if we can go to the next slide.
Yeah.
And then a final experiment
I want to discuss today is the
the robotic navigation or
like maybe more accurately
robotic control.
So here we took our Kuka platform
and we mount some sensors on top of it
and then also put it on a laptop
for good measure to have some compute.
And I don't think
the sensors are really relevant
for what we're going to discuss now. So
then we drove around to the robot
in our lab, as you can see on this movie,
just like with the joystick
and captured a lot of data
and we just drove up and down the ice
with the robots.
Now, this environment is also a bit
challenging for robots
since all these aisles are super similar,
like for robots
knowing if it's an aisle one or two,
it's nearly the same thing.
It's very difficult
to comprehend for the machine.
So then in this slide,
to see what a recording might look like.
So you have right
lie there and read our feet some images.
Yeah, sorry,
this is not a great slide.
And and then the goal is to and again
train
a model that will be able to generate
future observations for the robots.
I don't know if there's an animation
on the slides. Yeah.
So you saw the first, the high resolution
image was the real observation
and this is
then what the model thinks will happen
if the robot first turns right
and then continues to drive
the little ghost artifact.
You saw a bit a couple of frames ago,
so we'll first look at it again.
So we drive
and then it'll turn
and suddenly you will see a ghost.
Them appear.
And this is
because the model doesn't
actually know what will happen.
It can only try to guess
based on its previously
learned experiences in the model.
And there's a lot of people
walking around in the data sets.
So there was an assumption
that somebody would be walking there.
So just might imagine
that there's somebody there.
Then maybe if we go to the next slides
and this is also an animation,
so you can see, for example,
how these imaginary samples deviate.
And this is also the reason
why we need the sampling
and so the different sampling and
the buying tree for different outcomes.
So you see that given the same
starting position and observation,
the model learns that turning left
might have different outcomes
depending where it is
and there in which out of this
and we wear it in detail, for example,
the top right
then the robot imagines that it is
at the end of the aisle
whilst in the bottom to it
imagines that it is in the aisle.
So just imagine some stuff on the X
and here
is and how we can evaluate policies.
So we typically we provided
three possible policies
turn left or center right.
And then you can imagine what all
these things will do in the environments.
And then similarly as before you can
calculate the G
and select
the one that will most likely bring you
to your preferred sequences
and yeah, right.
So that's
also the nice thing of our model
is that
you can,
you can because of its because it's
a neural network, you can put multiple
types of observation into posterior
model, you can fuze them in various ways.
So what you can see here
is it's similar to the camera feed.
The robot will also learn the effect,
for example, in the lighter scan
and also it will learn the effects
on the velocity bins in a radar scan.
And this gives you of
course extra robustness in your planning
because you can
now reason on multiple modalities
that maybe in the next slides
there are still some limitations
to using robotic to do the control
this way.
First of all, our robot is extremely
short sighted and
in time it can only learn to predict
as far as the length of the sequence,
the speed provided during training.
And also the longer
you roll out, the larger
your search tree
becomes, the more computational.
But limits you will reach.
So this is also an area of,
you know, actively working on
and then currently our models
still require that we pre-record
the data set so that our models recovery,
that we drive around ourselves
and then fit the model.
So there's also a point
where currently at this moment working on
and then tying into this, our models
currently
do not really know how to explore.
Whilst
there's probably a sensible way to do
exploration based on the free energy
principle, since your model uncertainty
can be baked in
I think I don't know
if you have any more slides actually.
Now does it?
Maybe it's time for questions.
Awesome.
You can share
and we can ask some questions.
So I wrote down a bunch of stuff
and also anybody who's
watching live, please ask some questions.
So nice presentation though
and awesome, very instructive videos
hopefully made us think, made us laugh
a little bit with it.
Cut corners.
So maybe just a starting question
while people are writing their question,
what brought you to be studying
this topic?
In this way?
Were you coming from
active influence and saw robotics
as an interesting application,
or were you in the area of robotics
or then found active inference to
be a useful model?
Yeah, so basically we were area of
robotics and learning
and we were working on building
better,
more dimensional state representations
to feet into that reinforcement
learning algorithm.
Let's see the initial idea.
So just building representations
or or better for security.
And then we stumbled upon
the active inference framework, which
which basically not only gave us a way of
bottom of how to
to build models because basically we know
we found ourselves
the, let's say, the energy of the balls.
We were basically already doing that.
But we said it's also gives us
in the same mathematical framework
array of how to project these things
to the future and use this for planning,
for resolving ambiguity,
and also for scoring the whole D
and all these nice properties
that are basically lacking in oil.
So that's why we basically started
digging into this mathematical framework
to go through all the papers of all
and see
how all the ends or tied together
and see whether this would still work.
If you if you don't have your
your state space
defined problems,
but you just learn it from from data.
So that's how we started this endeavor.
And that's the mature area at this point.
And still
investigating it for
awesome.
That was going to be my second question
was like what differences or advantages
would you describe for active inference
over reinforcement
learning or other machine
learning frameworks?
If you answered it
previously, that's great.
Or do you want to add any other thoughts.
I think
I think the nice part is that you
you automatically gets the,
the nice properties of
of resolving ambiguity and of
potential expiration if you also
estimate positive distributions
over your benefits, for example.
So these are very interesting properties
mathematically.
However, it's still it's
there's still a gap
to actually get this all of
these revert cases.
If you if you if you don't have the
the model redefines itself.
So there are still some challenges
but the theory
at least
this is it's very much a feeling.
And I think if you look at
what's going on at the URLs site
that reinforce three sites, then
there's
not that big of a gap between fields.
I think because you look at all
the previous bonuses
that they tried to come up with in
and your first learning
and if you look at the model based stuff
like that is your ultimate approach,
then everything is kind of similar
in converging to it's a good idea
to build a model of your role,
get more simple efficiency,
and it seems like a good idea
to have some planning in there
and maybe there is some
there is some gaining curiosity.
And so you see that a lot in a lot of
different independent research tracks.
Really converge along the same lines.
And I think what's
what is so appealing for active inference
is that basically
it brings us all together from
from a single principle, which makes it
a very nice framework to work with.
I think.
Anything to add on that or something.
We had was before Tim mentioned
there was already thinking
along the lines
of the work of the Ninja Helper.
So I mean, if you look at his models
and I think that is
currently almost state of the art,
the mobile based URL,
then you will find that the models
they are building are very similar
to the models we are building or other
active interest researchers are building.
So yeah, I mean, it makes sense
that all these
approaches converge on a single idea
of the idea works yep.
Very interesting that
like plan to dream and dream
or imagine
so that you can sample appropriately.
Why put that as a second
layer on the model
or have to incentivize it
in a sort of ad hoc way?
Why not have that
be the basis of the model?
So that's a very nice point.
So Dean in the chat asks,
Have the authors heard of the Missionary
and Cannibals game slash problem,
which is moving
two kinds of mutually incompatible
agents back and forth
from two sides of a river?
And if they have heard of this
or thought of any kind of analogies
cases, do you see any applications
right?
Yeah, I haven't heard of the game before.
I think it's probably similar to the
like crossing the river with the chicken,
the fox and a goat or.
Yes. Or was. It?
Yeah, there's like animal versions.
There's all kinds of versions
of this one,
but going back and forth
with different kinds
of incompatible agents
and you need to sort of go to the left
before you can make it up the hill, but
it's a little bit of a different setting.
So what does that make you think of.
What.
And actually really considered that
for our models, but it might be
if you find a way
to model it in an environment
and then maybe collect some data on it.
Yeah.
I think this is a problem that this is
very nicely suited for doing.
It's, let's say, the vanilla way
where you basically
write out
all the different states that can happen
of the outcomes that you can have.
So I think you could
actually formalize it in such a way
and then run an insurance
simulation on, on that and see,
see what happens.
So that's less of our interest
because in our case
we are mainly interested in
what if your observations are so high
dimensional that you kind of even start
thinking about
writing out the model.
That's it.
And the only thing you can do is interact
with the environment
and try to learn it from, from the data,
which is
slightly different.
Take on the objective inference problem.
Great.
Another question is
you are all deploying these models
sort of real time with physical agents,
embodied agents.
So what surprised you
or what was interesting to note
as far as going from the simulation
only where you can sort of
put everything in a box and know
exactly what's going to influence
what to the world of embodiment
where I don't know,
some dust could get into the robot
or I saw a person walk by.
So what comes into play when you actually
deploy physically
and how does the model deal with that?
For me,
it's actually the thing I like first.
I play in the round
a lot with the month ago in the car,
but the first thing actually
was a real hurdle
for me personally was deploying it
on a real robot.
You suddenly have all these
hardware constraints like you can.
You don't have instant memory, you don't
have server, great compute anymore.
And you all have to. You have to.
Yeah, fit.
It's for example,
I think Tim and I spent a lot of time
to make a demo working
where we could roll this out real time
and just the hardware constraints
of doing something as complex as active
infants real time on a real power
constraint robot is another challenge.
I don't know if it's self
so. So I think
if the question was
what do you get from there,
from doing that on the real system?
Well, a lot of frustration and pain,
I think is the answer.
But likewise,
if you then if it works, then
it's just so much higher.
So I still remember older than me
cheering in the lab
because we gave the robots
the preferred state of being like nicely
in the center of Yale.
And it was actually moving along the L.
And then at the very end, they decided
this is not the center of the universe.
And it just made a 360 degree
turn and started driving back.
We were like, Oh, this is awesome.
So I think the there's lots of feelings
of frustration to get it to work.
But then once something comes out
and satisfaction
so much higher than then, when you see
a mounting priority, which is also.
Interesting,
you could set up a physical valley,
maybe make a physical mountain car
because there's so much comparison
of the software realization, but
maybe that would be even taking it
to the next level
so another thing that you talked about
repeatedly, maybe even in every example,
was actually training the model
from just a handful of human cases.
Like you drove the car, you had people
play the mountain car game.
So what exactly is happening there
and how does the model like not overfit
to the few trajectories you show or not
just say, Hey, you only gave me three?
What's the deal with these three?
Totally different trajectories,
like what exactly is being learned
or updated in the model when you provide
just a handful of human examples.
That.
Then we're going to answer this one.
So so basically
yeah, I think overfitting is
this is clearly an issue
you're
no matter what you do, your constraints
kind of through the data you provide
to the models which cannot really learn
anything else than what is obvious.
So that's also what
we pointed out at the loss.
So that's a severe limitation of work
during grunt work activity.
But there is
there is no other way
when there's a robot
involved to get started.
So a lot of the easier ways
to get started.
So that's mainly the, the driver.
But at the moment
we're actually working both in simulation
but also for real robots to see
when we actually get these
systems to decide how to
out of their own experience.
What it's interesting to learn from them
because that's actually one of the two
shortcut through
one of your previous questions about this
X of entrance, if you will, that
it actually can deal with this and stuff.
Things like my,
my Robert collects all his views
but they are always the same
or both explorer or self.
And so these are really connected
areas of research.
But then so to come back
to the overfitting problem,
so one thing that mitigates overfitting
a bit is the fact that you have
all these stresses in the system
in sample states
which makes it a bit more,
but it's not like a classifier
that that all fits the best of.
Let's say there's always some kind of
noise in there, but you're right
in this in some sense
or the data in the sense
that it's kind of predicts scenarios
that it really hasn't seen before.
But so one of the, one of the nice
things of having this
energy formulation is that you
actually finish
your planning to
read this entropy term,
which basically means that
if you plan ahead in some space,
that's the model wasn't rained on,
then typically you will have
some more variation, some higher entropy
or that area
because typically your your observation
becomes very bad or
very blurry or all of distribution.
And so so in some sense
the model is kind of robust against that.
And it will also
if you then deploy a policy
like that, do the planning,
it will kind of try to stay close
to where the model the regime
where the model was restrained.
OK, because there
you basically get the better predictions.
So in some sense
that also mitigates the problem.
So I want to add that
the by we
we could use as little of the rollouts
as we did because actually if you had
let a human do it roll out, you solved
the exploration problem for the agents.
You already get very good coverage
of the relevant, feasible state space.
You get like for the car racer.
If you let the random agent drive
around as exploration.
99% of your days will just be grass
and the robot will
learn nothing about robots.
So by having a human human drive it,
you know, this is the road.
And apparently this is important because
it's in every observation I've had.
That almost makes me think of two ways
that we're seeing these large models
be trained with a sort of mentor
like a human who says you know, here's
the first places you want to be sampling,
here's how you drive the first time.
That's the driving instructor
side by side.
And then there's the
the generative adversarial approach,
which is just the almost opposite.
Like we're going to be passing the model,
the most confusing possible data.
And so it's sort of like with this carrot
and the stick or the pushing the pole,
these models from both of them,
maybe one or maybe both,
they figure out
how to be on that razor's edge.
And then in the race car example,
it was cutting corners.
So that just made me wonder
about autonomous vehicles and you say,
OK, well, the goal is to stay on the road
and to get there fast,
but then sometimes get there
fast is going to take priority.
And then all of a sudden
you're way off the road
and maybe now your car is ruined
or something like that.
So if these were to be deployed, like
how will we even know
what kind of preferences
to instantiate the model with.
And that's it.
That's a very good point because
how nice
the inference might look in theory,
I think
it doesn't it's not a silver bullet
to autonomous agents
because a lot of the
a lot of uncertainty is still in.
How do you how do you provide it with
like the preferred prior distribution?
And that will be the commercial
in the real world system of
it's it's similar to do reward.
Basically, it's a bit more informative
than just to give a reward signal,
let's say
it suffers from the same issues as in
and if if it's right, that's
the way to do shortcuts.
You get this preferred states
that you didn't envision
before as a
as a designer of the experiment would say
it's basically has the same issues
as reinforcement learning.
So I don't see this as a silver bullet
of solving autonomy,
but at least it has some
it has some
dirty knobs that you can
you can,
you can use to at least avoid some cases
like avoid these ambiguous,
ambiguous states or
at least make it first,
learn the model properly.
So it has some nice properties,
but it's not a silver bullet
to solving autonomous systems.
I think
anything to add on that one.
I think Jim said it very well.
Yes, the model is not a silver bullet.
Definitely recognized
what areas might be.
Interesting.
Shooting ranges, first applications
where we can at least explore it.
Are those the same use cases
that people have been talking about
just more broadly
in terms of autonomous vehicles?
Or might there be sort of
division of labor where active inference
is going to specialize
like in those ambiguous scenarios?
Or I just was curious about that.
OK, so yeah,
I was also still thinking,
but like for us there, I think
the real next application worth
targeting is just still the constraints
navigation in that for example,
over at your house where
the impact of
mis planning is still fairly limited.
So the more realistic versions
of the situation we have in our lap,
maybe it's also that the trajectory
we're currently still on.
So I think we still believe
that there is some value in developing
autonomous active inference agents
for this more industry like settings
where you can at least separate
that from general public and more.
You have also some level of
control of the environments
hmm. Yeah.
I think they think it's similar to
to mitigating the same problem
of course is basically that you before,
before you just let the system randomly
pick actions or pick any action at once,
you kind of or an environment
where at least as a human you can
you can start to fix the system
and say, OK,
you want to drive forward into this
wreck, that's not a good idea.
So you have at least some
some ways of defining
some rules to keep it within some safety
range, let's say.
And within this boundary.
It's again, it's done, for example,
move autonomously,
but still then you might have
the nicer properties
of the active inference agent.
But it's if if you're driving around
in some ales and somebody
just dropped dropped off the box
in the middle of the EL,
it will not freak out because the the
slammer is is it's no longer
consistent with with how the robot
was programed, for example, before
just say, OK, this is another case
I didn't experience this before.
And it is it is really more an idea
how to cope with this part
will just be intrigued and start learning
about this new information.
So I think these are the nice properties
you have in these agents
and kind of by false the all
it's getting too greedy
to realize its preferences
because you kind of shortcut
these situations but by having this
this very rule based system in place
that kind of limits
the choice of eviction.
And thanks for the answer
here's a question from the chat.
As the code is not disclosed,
would you say
sticking to what you write in your paper
is sufficient to reproduce your results?
Or are there any further tricks you use
in designing and training the models.
I think that I.
Sorry, go ahead. Them first.
Yeah,
I think that together with your finishes,
it should be sufficient when you think.
Well, I think, well,
we had some experience, but
I try to help somebody out with trying
to replicate their results and
I think the
we have some tricks for the planning.
I think that isn't as straightforward
to replicate, but
the model prediction parts,
we explained the architectures
and I pretty detailed in the appendix.
So I think and we don't do
any exact tricks, for example,
on data processing or our long term.
So this would be easy to mimic,
but I think the planning is a bit
more involved as we
sometimes ourselves have difficulties
replicating. It's
planning is hard.
Yeah.
OK. If
anyone else has questions
in the live chat, they can type that.
Another piece that I thought
was really fascinating in the mountain
car example at least was
how you talked about the noise allowing
for the previously implausible policies
to become possible.
Like we saw a broader
spread of the of the trajectories
when there was noise.
How, how is that being like
integrated in real time?
Or how are the noise,
which are often very small?
How does that change the models
understanding of where it can go
and what it should do.
So in the multicore
example,
there are basically two sources of noise
that say one is on on the noise
on your observation that you get
so you get the versus the noise noisy
estimate of your position.
And so this is typically not
not so large because you need to have
the sufficient signal to noise ratio
just to learn anything.
Let's say
but the
second part was whether your agent starts
with a zero velocity
or it's a random velocity
and these are basically
two separate trains models.
So either you you have an agent
always starts with zero initial velocity
and then basically the model learns that
the initial observation
has zero velocity
and it basically knows how
to properly predicts
from from the first observation.
Let's see if you train the model
where the agent has a random velocity,
then it basically learns
that from the first observation.
So a lot of options can happen
depending on my velocity.
And the more observations
then you see how the model gains or
picks up, OK, this is now my philosophy
and from then on you
see how the wide range of options
collapses to the
most, the most likely means.
Anything on that?
Amazon.
Well, I was also thinking, for example,
in the robotic planning example
we gave there, you also see the spreads,
but then it's more as in
that the model learned
that it's different.
It's similar state values
different outcomes are possible.
So it will try to maybe make the gosh
and in the latest in a bit wider
so that if you sample from it's
you might get a slightly
different sample value and that will then
generate the different outcome you want
you want to visualize.
So that's also so even though
the standard normal you're sampling from
initially for every preference position
trick is very just standard normal.
The model can learn to inflate
or deflate this distribution
so that you get a wider coverage.
If for example, if
you also saw in the investigation example
is that basically the the model
since you train it on on really short
central step sequences
of like I think one or 2 seconds
and you kind of
so it's not able to cost
you guys a very consistent prediction
for or longer time
frames then that and also given the fact
that every El in the lab
looks very similar,
it learns the general structure
like there are wrecks left and right
and there might be boxes or,
or you saw the spine of the boxes
or the stuff in the end is actually
indirect, sustained, very blurry.
And it's kind of brownish blackish,
but there's no real
you can identify ones in the direct,
for example, and it's
so it has basically no
spatial awareness of rare in the
MDMA at the very end or beginning
or in the middle.
It has no idea.
And that's why you saw
if you don't see their rights
for a certain amount of time, then
it will either predict I'm in the middle.
So the next that if I turn 360, it will
still be ale after me or at the very end.
So if I turn around, I will see a wall.
So in this just no
systems knowledge of of this.
And so the this is basically model,
this kind of noise
in the institutions and if you
if you draw a different trajectory,
I think it's at the wall or
it's facing the other ale
or just a human passing by.
So I see some shady
people like Earth strictures.
So all of these kind of things are
then model.
This is kind of.
Yeah, noise
in your, in your distribution
that just appears to be happening there.
It makes sense
what might be helpful
or required for long term planning
because the, the tree
that you had with a multiple,
I guess Bifurcations or whatever
they represented,
that was very interesting how
you had a very fully fleshed out tree.
And then you showed
kind of how you recurse to prune
back down to make a policy selection.
So as you suggested, that
exponentially explodes the computation.
What might be helpful
or how can long term
planning
be achieved with reasonable hardware?
Yeah, so so the
the key thing here
is, is hierarchical models.
And that's what we're
we're pushing very hard
now is basically that you
given your given model
like retreat treat,
now you're basically the new model
on top of this
that now as observations
does not gets doesn't get pixels
but it gets state samples from this model
this and that.
The same step
now is not to predict the next step ahead
but like who give them sense of the type
or country
or whatever
or however you want to in this.
And once you're at that point,
then you have basically a system
that can then plan
if you plan templates
that you're actually planning over time
steps for the lower level model.
And so this way you can keep on course
grading that.
You only have to
explore if you policies at each level.
And then down below again, you only have
to predict for like one second.
That's because the other plan
was made for by the models.
And so this way you can, you can easily
bypass that and scale down
the complexity of the planning procedure.
So it reminds me a lot of driving
where it will be like,
OK, in five streets, take a right turn.
So you're not
pre staging the right turn.
OK, one, two, three, four.
All right. Now I should get ready.
What about symbolic information?
Like what if the aisle had a color
or gradients or if it had one
dot to dot three dot, could that be
learned in an unsupervised way?
A symbol in that pixel level model,
or is that where a hierarchical model
would come into play?
Well, I think the problem
currently is for us, architecture wise,
our model isn't capable of capturing
very like low level
details about the environments
just because
we are based on a V approach.
And then the means get objective
the use for reconstruction
and the way we sample
is already inhibiting,
for example,
recognizing dots in your inputs
and maybe I don't know what thing
then thinks about that.
I think color gradients
is something like the model might learn
if given enough data and incentive.
Yeah.
So I think there's a number of problems
with with the approach in the sense
that we're now doing prediction
and in, in pixel space it's safe
and the way you calculate the likelihoods
you evaluate the likelihood and you,
you go to the reconstruction area,
it basically means that
you want to have each pixel independently
predicted on average growth rates,
which means that
if you have very fine grained details, it
easily
ignores this.
You also have the,
the complexity term that basically says,
OK, I want to have the
the complex representation
for for reconstruction or reconstruction.
But this basically also means that
depending on
how much you you put pressure on
restricting the complexity,
the less information
you will actually and cohesion,
the more lower your base for your
your reconstruction will become it's
very similar to the base of the i.e.,
those where you have this better
parameter that the how much weight
you put on the yellow divergence
term versus the reconstruction.
Third,
and this also has
an impact on what the model will actually
within the state representation
and which details will
there be will be ignored.
And so yeah, I think
a lot of these things are very difficult
for the model of the street
now just because the way we rebuilt
and Bernard tries to like the model
very interesting.
How might somebody go about
learning or exploring this like
is there a textbook
or the citations
that are in your paper or hands on?
What would you encourage
somebody who is curious about this
and wanted to over the next
maybe few years
be following
yeah.
I mean, we had a lot of like
in the act of infant sports.
I think when we started out there
wasn't that much information
on how to do active inference.
So we had to figure it out the hard way
by trying a lot and failing a lot.
But now currently I think
even in this model stream, there was some
cool information and accessible
information on active inference.
So and
I mean specific implementation wise,
if you want to build a model
like this, I think the current state
of the art and URL and
active inference learned
active inference is or pretty similar
yeah.
I agree. So
a lot of things
have changed regarding our accessibility
information on active influence
has become if you look now
at the tutorial from MIT, for example,
which was also extensively covered
in one of your videos,
so I think that's really, really
those the, the, the entry bar
to just get to know the theory
and how everything works or should work
and to play around with some small play
examples and simulations
that you can get some insights on
and what does this thing do.
And obviously
the, the deep learning path, it's safe
to build these models.
Then probably the,
the resource to go through
are just like the photos and variation
with open borders.
I think these are the, the, the things
in learning that are most relevant for,
for or for the active inference work
we discussed here.
And if you can build the variation
also encoder
and you know how active inference work
and you push it
through together, together, generate
some details from our paper, for example.
So I think it should be
pretty straightforward
that to the first example.
Pool any closing thoughts
or even questions for our lab
or just to leave for people
to be thinking about
as they dream in preparation
for action.
Yeah.
Maybe I just want to
continue a bit on what them said
earlier that
for example,
if you want to build hierarchical models,
you don't have to build a negative
influence
model on top of an infinite model.
We experiment some
we did some preliminary experiments on,
for example,
just using our active infinite model as
dynamics, the model for a slam algorithm.
And then you also already get
hierarchical modeling
and some of the long term benefits.
So maybe that's also interesting like
to think about this,
how this active fits.
It's in an already existing techniques.
Yeah, so I think that
what goes on to say that
in this case
we use like these deep neural nets.
So the first rise, this transition
model like this model and
the super model, but
you shouldn't always
reverse automatically do this
kind of very popular right now.
Very, very cool.
But in some cases you might
it might be sufficient
if you know your environments
then, yeah, you shouldn't
bother learning the states be all this.
No, the states is little.
Just Yeah.
Use it or I know
you use the multi-core example here
this would be a good example of
why we shouldn't
just use the deep learning approach.
And so this is just like a proof
of principle work for us
to get some simple example working,
but it only pays off.
I think if you have like these real high
dimensional observations
and you don't,
you have no clue how to predict in space.
This will.
But it's not that this is like the,
the default way to go, let's say.
And we also like kind of evolving,
especially also
if you move through
these hierarchical models that we kind of
looking at, how can we make the
more kind of discrete style
bridge right states based model on top?
Very, very basically.
Right.
Good to the whole states phase
into discrete parts
and then have like a simple transition
model.
Like you give the example yourself if you
if you think about navigating yourself,
you're not thinking about predicting
all the pixels of all the houses
or but you just think about
I need to go forward now
and then the second street to the left.
So you basically think of the whole
continuously state space
and through some relevant parts.
And then your transition model
also becomes like the very simple
matrix with which position probabilities.
And so I think the future
is in the models
and the future is in a mixture
of some parts, but also some,
some very precise,
intuitively comprehensible parts.
Just two points on that.
One is something that's always drawn
me to active inference is that it's
inference conditioned and about action
so you're not going for that
for K Google Street View,
what does every house look like?
And again, when that's the input data,
even if you have a generative model,
that's the output data.
So active inference
is a really principled way to just
sort of reduce what you're predicting to
like which way should my elbow move
not what will
the pixels look like when my elbow moves,
which may be just
taking gigabytes of data,
but if it's just reduced to the state
space, then it's easier to learn.
And that's why it was such an interesting
contribution with your paper
to actually learn that state space
in the context of high resolution
and real time and heterogeneous sensors.
And then also it's something
that we've seen many perspectives on
in the lab and in these discussions
is there's the philosophical discussion
map and territory
who's really an active inference agent?
Is it
everything, a dust particle, a bacteria,
you know, is the world built this way?
And then there's
this sort of engineering approach
where you have your preferences
for how you want to see the robot work,
and then whatever
you can tinker and cobble together
that satisfies you.
And it
reduced your uncertainty about performing
the tasks you're trying to perform.
So it's sort of sidesteps,
but then it sidesteps
those questions in a way
that actually brings us to a higher level
of understanding,
because I know that many listeners
who are not as advanced in the machine
learning will be inspired
and have qualitative thoughts
based upon what you brought here today.
So thanks again for this
awesome presentation and conversation
and we'll always appreciate hearing
any follow up, whatever the time is right
yeah.
Thank you for having us this discussion.
OK, peace.
See you later. Bye bye.